Hello! You're watching Mostly Weekly
and I am unfortunately Andrew Heaton.
Puerto Rico, it's Spanish for 'rich port'
which is sort of ironic because it's bankrupt.
Kinda like how Iceland isn't full of ice
and Greenland isn't very green
and Lonely Island has lots of fans.
Islands are liars!
But now poor puerto is even less rico.
A month ago the vicious category 4 hurricane
Maria
ripped through the island razing a 50 to 60
mile swath of destruction.
But the worst part of this tragedy, and I
think we can all agree on this,
is that we didn't-
appreciate Donald Trump
enough.
But luckily, Puerto Ricans have been spared the
onslaught
of Donald Trump's category 5 man-baby tweet
storm.
Why?
Because 90% of Puerto Rico is still without
power and 88% are without cell reception.
And it's gonna be at least 6 months before
power is restored.
How is this even possible?
To answer that question we have to rewind
the clock 5 months ago to May 3rd,
or two White House Communication Directors
ago,
when Puerto Rico filed for bankruptcy.
It couldn't pay the 70 billion dollars it
owed to creditors,
and that's because the country's been in economic
decline since 2006.
So to answer why Puerto Rico looked like this,
and now looks like this,
we have to ask: 'Why the island's been in
economic freefall since 2006?'
and the answer is:
Government, that's my final answer.
Puerto Rico is without power for three reasons.
We raised taxes, which led to a deficit, which
led to a brain drain, which led to a deficit.
The United States and Puerto Rico had been
flirting for years
since the Spanish American War.
Then the United States finally put a ring
on it in 1952
and Puerto Rico became a US commonwealth,
and they decided to raise a couple of beautiful
industries together.
So the United States showered Puerto Rico
with corporate tax breaks.
But then the honeymoon phase ended in 1996,
the US phased out those tax breaks.
Businesses fled the island and to make up
the difference,
the Puerto Rican government started binge
eating debt.
So faced with a whopping 70 billion dollar
debt to Wall Street creditors,
many Puerto Ricans bailed for the mainland.
The Puerto Rican economy has been so wrecked
that there are now more Puerto Ricans living
outside Puerto Rico than in.
Bad news for Puerto Rico, but:
great news for
the New York Puerto Rican Pride Parade.
This results in a brain drain
and this labor exodus makes paying back a deficit extremely hard.
It's like trying to fill a hole, but all you
have is more holes.
We made imported goods more expensive.
In 1920 the US passed the Jones Act,
which requires all goods shipped between US
ports to be transported by US vessels.
Meaning that Puerto Rico depends on the US
ships, which make imports way more expensive.
Which is cool 'cause it's not like Puerto
Rico imports 84% of it's food, right?
Ha! 'cause that'd be crazy!
After the Hurricane, President Trump suspended the Jones Act
with the break neck reaction speed of-
six days, but hey!
He had more important kneeling-related matters
to attend to.
However residents are still suffering from
years of artificially high import prices.
So even though 43.5% of residents live below
the poverty line,
it's still crazy expensive to live there.
Don't believe me?
Pssst!
Hey buddy, wanna buy some sugar?
Only 40% more than mainland prices.
PREPA, Puerto Rico's publicly run electrical
grid,
adopted a hipster approach to electricity,
complete with dilapidated facilities and vintage
technology.
Instead of using modern energy sources,
Puerto Rico still generates two thirds of
it's power through burning
good old-fashioned petroleum,
which is very steam punk and retro and dumb.
Why?
because all that oil has to be imported and
requires a skilled workforce.
So what happens when you have to import expensive
oil
and handle it with a workforce that's decreased
by a third over the past five years?
This.
But there's hope.
In a state of emergency the Puerto Rican government
can bypass permits
and immediately revoke regulations.
Also, private citizens are turning to the
black market to put the lights back on.
In an ongoing effort to become the Batman,
Elon Musk has offered to save Puerto Rico's
electrical grid
with batteries and solar power.
Making Puerto Rico the Lois Lane of electrical
grids.
But the more important thing is that Puerto
Rico is without power
and it was an avoidable catastrophe.
We shouldn't have to reach a state of emergency
to discover the devastating effects of taxation
and excessive regulation.
And because Puerto Rico is without power,
people are going to die from heat stroke,
the clean water supply is restricted and the
supply of food and drugs has shrunk.
Worst of all:
we didn't sufficiently appreciate Donald Trump.